So libraries,
what exactly do we mean by a library?
I love books but that's not the kind
of library we're talking about.
Instead, a library is a packaged
collection of reusable code which
you include in your app rather
than starting from scratch.
We've already used a few
libraries with Sunshine.
We used AppCompat in
Android Fundamentals One
to build a consistent look and
feel across all API levels.
And the Support Library Annotations,
just recently, to add a little
bit more type safety to our code.
We certainly could have done all that
ourselves, or skipped it entirely, but
libraries can often help you
achieve the best user experience
without you writing and
maintaining a ton of extra code.
Even better, Popular libraries often
have a strong community following and
a large number of people who can
help you answer your questions.
Not usually the case with your own code.